[Music]
in music goggles news more submitted by
chicken feet oh that's a delicacy yeah
yeah you eat that you can eat this I eat
it you know you've never tried it before
no I was deathly afraid of it just give
it some time
just give it some time because it took
me about seven years that's like I've
heard like a gay dude sucks your dick
better study suggests that listening to
highly arousing songs makes women find
males faces more attractive you know
what I should do is play harder that's
true that's why you always see a bunch
of Korean church kids play the guitar oh
dude the kids with the guitars got laid
yeah absolutely that's how you play now
the only reason why I had no the kit was
in my high school is the kids with the
drugs always got laid the girls wanted
free drugs yeah roofies work really good
I kid
researchers from the University of
Vienna they were looking at the effect
of music on sexual attraction so if they
did in their study they presented why do
you need a study just look at a sure
what the [ __ ] does they have too much
money that was
yeah they got a grant from something
that you know they shuffled money
somewhere else instead of look at Chris
Brown he just constantly beats up
Rihanna and the women still love him
slug it insane yeah but I think it's
more about like can music make you think
an ugly guy is a trap more well hundred
percent okay that's Sharon so many
studies it's like a million dollars and
they found out that stepping on oranges
relaxing what the [ __ ] are you doing
over there
that'd take that much money to do it
right pocket it it was so relaxing right
now I want to try it we found some
people think it's not molest but most
people do yeah thank you for this study
it was a 20-year study should say that
Steve could that make sure not all for
progression dude I don't know I'm
against science yeah you're actually
right
so in their study the researchers
presented 96 heterosexual participants
with musical excerpts followed by a
photograph of a face from the opposite
sex with a neutral facial expression so
then the participants were asked to
assess the face in terms of
attractiveness on a scale and to say
whether they would date the person that
was pictured and so to test the
effectiveness of the music in another
study the participants were shown faces
without the music and so what they found
is that female participants rated male
faces more attractive and were more
willing to date these men while they
were listening to the music of course
that's like foreplay a growth you're not
receptive to whatever you gonna do if
you have foreplay say [ __ ] it's like
when I want you actually movie in the
mic I'm gonna drive fast right now
like just watch some shitty fast movie
and you're like cool yeah surprisingly
about the fact was not seen with male
participant oh yeah cuz it's probably
like a good if it's the same song and if
it's like sappy if it's the Drake or
something and I mean if it's a guy
singing I don't it's hard for a guy to
get aroused with the guy what if it's
like Selena Gomez whispering in your ear
no what is she whispering why she's
saying why it's cuz Joe watches
weird-ass born there yeah
wasn't called the transsexual corridor
whatever dude she's trying to reach your
level man accommodating girlfriend thank
you so much you trying to grow a penis
so you can make me happy that's awesome
I feel this sense I think if Selena
Gomez was in my ear and she whispered
suck my dick I'd be like okay let's see
it lets see it I'm pretty confident you
don't go on a completely objective view
the see Selena Gomez from 1 to 10 and
unattractive scale physically what is it
to you guys I can't even [ __ ] picture
did hashtag women helping women do I
think it's important no I think it's
more important now than ever
celebrity to me Jennifer Lopez why am I
going all Mexican I don't know I like
Emily Ratajkowski art piece today you
know what's funny is I've never actually
seen an Emily Ratajkowski face okay but
I need to figure that out cuz you said
her name in my mic our boobs popped in
my head and I'm like what's her [ __ ]
face look like she's very pretty
why what was your question 1 to 10 Elena
Gomez physical scale one because she's
hot I think she's attractive
so you give like a one a six or seven
unattractiveness yeah look at your
homework
no it's cuz she's popped up Selena Gomez
it's good she's on the side of the
article that's crazy
I see Selena Gomez naked and then I'll
see ya what guys do by the way as if
were any better ourselves yeah yeah butt
naked I would say she's hot in this
photo oh god [ __ ] them you should have
picked the maximum that's right
right okay so if she came up to you and
said suck my dick that's not I just I
don't find her face attractive what good
it's baby thing it's not just baby face
it also looks like the gravity is all
here you're talking about it as if she's
a three no no I said
she wants you to suck her dick no I'm
just saying just like I said this is
just me I'm talking about in celebrity
world right not in regular human world
right we're not in my world she's above
my trucha celebrity world it's like okay
so in regular world it's one at ten in
regular walks you look at dinner and its
celebrity world it's 10 to 20 I gotta be
honest I wouldn't [ __ ] because I'm too
hot I'm just too hot for her I'm just
picturing her with a throbbing dick man
you [ __ ] it up why is that the robbing
it's hard so she's allowed you don't
want to picture a flaccid Gus - good
point
damn dude that's true she makes fun of
my flaccid dick I feel so ashamed I can
feel shame to death there's only because
you're not a girl with the dig that's
why she's not attract to you right now
is that what you really want Selena
Gomez with the dick I like that she had
to say no out loud I really want her to
say that - well I'm sorry I'm not a
Latina with a throbbing boner anyway
yeah so why were you reading her I don't
know I brought it up
wait what the [ __ ] I'm talking about it
doesn't work on men because we can't
focus on [ __ ] ya know cuz guys go like
there's no emotional connection to act
attractiveness it's just hot or not
that's very true say during sex right
when you have either music or a dead
quiet room where you can [ __ ] hear
crickets like which one's better I don't
like music I don't like music I don't
like music it's distracting it's [ __ ]
boring with that I like
lyrics I hate the foot you hear all you
hear is I got a you're thinking about
the wrong [ __ ] then done I shouldn't be
thinking about none of that stuff I'm
think of all I can think about think
about it go inside oh I like hearing the
sounds you just gotta hear your own
sounds you got a moan girl you got a
moan girl you got a talk [ __ ] he got a
talk I hope you gotta hear some sound to
like take my mind off into shape wait
what you want to go to space when you
having sex you being in the moment
[ __ ] I wanna be doing it in space yeah
that's why you're sad music Joe [ __ ] me
the space okay you know what
but he's gotten the closest anyone else
has ever get like a hundred percent
that's awesome Joe it's always like
you're like you're getting there Joe
when you were a kid you watched Marvin
the Martian you like okay sorry [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] batteries no I realize when
we do have sex and the music's not on
I'm sitting there and I just hear are
you [ __ ] to like the Doobie Brothers
like a soundtrack to make a music video
like when you work when you work on
something and you like the music it just
kind of gets the flow going so like for
me like if it's quiet I can hear him
[ __ ] breathing and like I don't know
it's just weird
yeah breeze [ __ ] weird I'm sorry oh
my god I love it Joe's like I grew up
with a disappointed Asian dad and now I
got a disappointed white lady white lady
that's funny
hey when we [ __ ] can you stop breathing
hey can you [ __ ] me to space a little
harder yeah I feel like people who like
to have sex and dead quiet are [ __ ]
weird and that's I'm sticking to my but
it's not dead quiet passion yes you
start off with this right and then it
gets like this like I don't think that's
sexy I think it's it makes you get into
more no I mean it's like somebody's
applauding you while you're [ __ ]
what's wrong with that yes I hope you
guys enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]
you
[Music]